do you remember the Tesla cyber truck so
they have this 2019 prototype on display
in the Peterson Museum in California
right now and like you can walk right up
to it and get a much closer personal
look at this thing which is exactly what
I did I put a full video on the
autofocus Channel if you want to check
it out but two main things really come
to mind that stuck out when seeing us
again one is several electric pickup
trucks have come out since this was
unveiled in 2019. the rivion r1t which
is incredible the Hummer pickup truck
which is very expensive but then also
the Ford F-150 Lightning is shipping so
the cybertruck's main advantage of being
first doesn't exist anymore it's going
to have to shift to being maybe the
longest range one or the lowest priced
one or just the one with the craziest
design but then two this this truck is
massive like there was some talk about
potentially shrinking it in every
Dimension but as of right now it's
roughly the same length width and height
as a Ford F-250 it's it's gonna be a
serious sight to see if and when this
truck finally does hit the streets
looking like a giant triangular sheet
metal render